so today we're going to be making a
camera trap why would you want to make a
camera trap well maybe a check and see
who's been sneaking cookies from the
cookie jar or if someone is going in
your room when they're not supposed to
you can even tweak it to catch wildlife
in your backyard so you're going to need
a mini digital camera a breadboard
jumper wires some extra longer wire an
Arduino 220 ohm resistor and a 10k
resistor and an infrared emitter and
detector
you'll also need a soldering iron solder
and batteries the first thing we're
going to do is take apart our digital
camera here's maybe a slightly different
model for mine but that's okay the
insides will be the same first we're
going to pry apart its plastic body now
you'll see a power mode switch and the
shutter switch we're going to solder two
wires to the leads of the shutter switch
so that we can control when it's being
pressed
you can also solder two leads to the
power mode switch if you want to control
that turning on and off with a diode
let's go ahead and put that aside for
now and we're going to upload code to
our Arduino you can find the code in
Wired comms how-to section once you've
compiled and uploaded the code we're
going to go back to our board you may
notice that this doesn't look like a
typical Arduino board that's because
it's evokes do we know but it does
exactly the same thing first let's
connect ground now from pin 2 of the
board we're going to connect our IR
emitter a 220 ohm resistor and we're
going to connect that to ground from the
5 volt pin in our board we're going to
connect a 10k resistor and connect that
to pin 3 in series with our resistor is
the IR detector and then we're going to
connect that to ground now we're going
to connect our camera to the circuit I
soldered wires to the positive and
ground leads where the battery would
normally go and I'm using a single
triple-a battery hooked into the rails
of our breadboard
never
to connect one wire from the camera
shutter switch to pin four and the other
to ground if you're not sure if your IR
emitter is hooked up correctly you can
use any camera with a CCD sensor
including an iPhone so here's our
finished circuit if something crosses
the infrared beam the camera will snap a
picture pretty useful huh
this is about as basic as the circuit
gets but if you want it to be more
practical you're going to have to
separate the emitter and the detector
and then you're going to want to stow
away the circuit and the camera
someplace hidden from view